you know one of these years I'll get to
kick off pride in a more enjoyable way
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there everybody so I said in a few
places including the community tab on
this channel as well as on Twitter that
I am NOT going to make a video talking
about JK Rowling and the latest things
that she said I made a video already
back in December talking about the last
round of things and nothing that has
come to pass in the last I guess week or
so in terms of when this goes live has
done anything to alter that perception
it's only solidified it if you want to
break down of what's gone on I'm gonna
recommend a video by Jessie gender she
does a really great job explaining what
was said and why it's a problem link in
the description but the whole thing did
so spurn on a train of thought so Wow I
not going to talk about any of that
specifically I am gonna talk about the
broader topic of consuming and
processing media that you love created
by problematic individuals now I'm gonna
talk about this in pretty broad terms
and there but there are three main
examples that I am gonna keep coming
back to now if you like the works of
these three people that's fine if you
actually are intending to go to bat for
these people I would rather you did not
because I have a problem with you
defending them but because I'm not
trying to do take to hounds of the three
things I'm going to mainly be citing I'm
simply using them as examples this is a
broad topic with lots of application so
when it comes
ooh creators or things of that nature
that we find out bad things about and
that's usually the way it is it's pretty
rare that someone who already has done
or has said really detestable things
create something that people enjoy after
that is public usually the creation of
whatever it is they're known for is
going to happen first now in terms of
whatever is the objectionable thing it
comes in two main flavors detestable
actions and detestable beliefs
detestable actions is not really what
I'm going to be talking about today
because honestly I think that one might
even be more sort of personal engaged
because it really just depends on what
sort of things are enough to push your
own personal factor so you may or may
not be able to still watch films by
Woody Allen or Roman Polanski or listen
to the comedy of Bill Cosby or watch a
movie with Kevin Spacey that's a
personal call and I think in cases like
that a lot of is just gonna have to do
with your own personal level of about
all of that the other thing is I am
going to be talking about well the
examples I'm gonna stay I'm gonna cite
our primarily authors and there's a
reason for that as well because when you
talk about larger art forms like say
film or video games is another good
example it can become a little bit of a
hair splitting exercise in trying to
determine how much was the person who I
have problems with contributing to this
whole thing for myself
Harvey Weinstein absolutely atrocious
human being produced a lot of really
good movies that I will probably
continue to watch because as a producer
he was not the creative force behind
them he was the financial force behind
them now it is probably still a fact
that those movies would not have been
made or at least not would not have been
made in in the way that they were
without his involvement but I still feel
like you're not gonna feel his hands on
the project in terms of taking it in as
a piece of art and with something like
videogames or anything with a large
development team or today take something
like Minecraft it gets even more
complicated there's a number of reasons
why some people have a lot of issues
with the original creator of minecraft
known as not but the thing is he's not
directly involved with the game anymore
and it's an ongoing constantly updated
thing so it's an evolving piece of art
and entertainment that the person that a
lot of people have issues with doesn't
touch anymore is that enough of an issue
I don't know
and that's actually gonna be part of the
thing here I'm not gonna tell you how to
process this I'm not gonna tell you what
you should do but I am gonna talk
through the phenomenon in general
because I think the one thing you
shouldn't be doing is ignoring it and
pretending like it's not there I'd like
is that I'm not really gonna focus on
objectionable actions I'm gonna focus
primarily on objectionable beliefs
thoughts statements so when you run into
that with creators you're usually
dealing with one of three scenarios
either the beliefs that they have that
you find objectionable are not in
evidence in the work itself
meaning that whatever it is that they
have said or believe that you have
serious problems with that does not
appear to be a core feature of the
stories that you enjoy from them so
that's one possibility there is the
possibility that the things that this
person is espousing appear to be in
direct contradiction to the themes of
the work that you love by them but then
there's also the possibility that the
objectionable things about this person
are very evident in the work and may
even be central to the work and we're
going to talk about all three of these
but before even that let's also talk
about
whether or not the objectionable creator
is still alive because if they are
deceased if they are passed away then
you don't have to you don't have to
parse the fact that enjoying their art
or buying art by them or if it's a
franchise style thing getting
merchandise that is branded with the art
that they have created that is not going
to financially benefit them directly if
they're dead if they're alive you do
have to come to terms with that to some
degree it may also depend on how much
research you're willing to do because
depending on the nature of certain
merchandising deals or deals for film
rights or things like that they may or
may not get residuals on a like a per
purchase basis and it may have been they
were just paid once for a merchandising
thing and they've already got their
money and you're not really contributing
to them if you want to do the research
to figure out what the residual scheme
is for those people more power to you I
don't have it in me to do that but if
you want to go to those lines you can if
the idea of putting money towards people
with fundamentally objectionable beliefs
to you you know as far as that goes if
you want to put in the work go for it I
can't I don't have it in me
so except there's three examples that
I'm primarily gonna be exciting because
they're gonna cover all three of the
situation's I talked about I'm going to
be discussing Orson Scott Card JK
Rowling and HP Lovecraft I'm going to be
talking about somebody with homophobic
beliefs transphobic police and racist
beliefs now again if you don't find
those beliefs that they have to be
objectionable just imagine applying this
elsewhere so let's start with Orson
Scott Card who is the writer of Ender's
Game now I need to confess upfront I
have not actually read Ender's Game so
this is the one I am speaking on with
least amount of authority because I am
going off of a little bit of research
that I've done into the work I have
never read it and I don't intend to
because I know too much about Orson
Scott Card and he's deeply homophobic
beliefs now this is an example of the
first thing that I mentioned at least so
far as I understand the work and looking
at the themes and write-ups about it etc
homophobia is not core to and homophobic
mentality is not core to Ender's Game it
may show up in some of his other works
but let's be honest Ender's games with
the guys best known for its it's going
to be his legacy always in forever and
that is a story about manipulation
rebelling against Authority about trauma
to a certain extent it's about
conditioning its dealing with a lot of
things but not a ton of which draw a
direct applicable transition into as
being espoused as homophobic or or being
any kind of analog for that so that is a
case where the work doesn't really
appear to crossover with the beliefs
with JK Rowling we actually have a case
where the beliefs that she espouses in
regards to the intolerance she appears
to have towards transgender people the
very idea of intolerance is antithetical
to a lot of the themes of Harry Potter
which is about finding your place in the
world finding other people like you
coming into your own and discovering
things about yourself and finding a
place in the in the world or discovering
a world in which you fit better than the
one in which you previously existed
these are specifically trans themes but
they are highly inclusive themes
so the idea that she holds exclusionary
beliefs is actually in opposition to the
themes of the work that she is best
known for which makes it a little bit
weird Lovecraft and Lovecraft's racism
so here's the thing about Lovecraft
people have tried to defend him saying
you know for the time that he wrote
everyone was racist possible or at least
most white people in New England might
have been to a certain extent but if you
look into the guy very much even for the
time he was a bit much but more to the
point whether he is more or less racist
for the era doesn't matter his racism is
actually core to the type of story that
he writes I don't just mean because
there are a handful of his stories with
specific instances of you know very
badly caricatured and nastily written
non-white characters even in ones where
only white characters appear what is the
core of his horror it is fear of the
unknown and if you look into Lovecraft
at all his major fear in real life of
the unknown had to do with people that
didn't look like him he had a lot of
fear around that and he poured it into
his work and extrapolated out into this
cosmic level which is honestly is what a
lot of good horror does it takes a fear
that the creator has and expands it and
blows it up into something bigger and
more horrifying and a little bit less
specifically personal to them so taking
this fear of these people out there that
I don't understand and I'm afraid of and
blowing it up into the sphere of these
entities that are inconceivable and
dangerous that's what you get
but that core belief that fear of the
unknown his fear of the world he didn't
understand and of people he could not
relate to is that the thematic heart of
nearly everything he ever wrote does
this mean you cannot enjoy these works
because the fact that he was a racist is
probably a big part of the reason why he
wrote what he wrote in the way he wrote
it even in stories where race does not
enter into the narrative directly can
you still enjoy the works of JK Rowling
and anything related to Harry Potter
when she is espousing this anti trans
sentiment or Orson Scott Card who
actively campaigned and like contributed
money towards political causes to try
and stop homosexual rights can you still
enjoy their works like I said that is a
personal call in a lot of ways but as
someone who is rather fond of the
concept of death of the author I think
it's possible I would say it depending
on your feelings about the financial
things maybe you don't want to
contribute more money to them so the
question for me becomes can you still
read the works that they have put
forward and find enjoyment in them
some people can some people can't but
the thing to remember is your read of
their work is yours the experience that
you had reading the stories that they
wrote is your experience whether it was
the one they intended for you to have
whether your experience and your way of
connecting with these works is
antithetical to the beliefs of the
author your experience cannot be taken
away from you and I think with something
like Harry Potter where not only the
works but the
fandom has largely pushed back Daniel
Radcliffe the actor who played Harry
Potter wrote a wonderful piece in some
in support of transgender people and
trans rights she may have created this
world but she does not get to dictate
how people connect with it and she does
not get to dictate the fandom I had
notes that I wrote down for this sort of
sketch out this video and what I was
going to talk about and it's in a
notebook with the marauders map on it
from Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban and I'm not getting rid of this
because this was a gift one of my
subscribers sent this to me and so the
way that I relate to this is not by
connecting it to her but by connecting
it to someone who likes what I do and
sent me a lovely gift and I am going to
use it and I don't have to think about
her when I do I'm going to continue to
read the Harry Potter books to my child
because she enjoys them because I can
have this I can reframe my experience of
Harry Potter as my reading these to her
and sharing these stories with her it
does not have to be my relationship with
the writer I can make it about my
relationship with my daughter my
daughter's not transphobic there are
things we can do to reclaim whether it
is finding a way to reframe your
experience of the work kind of like what
I'm doing with Harry Potter and getting
to read it to my kid whether it is
creating fan art
fiction that takes the characters and
puts them into the perspective that you
connect with best that can help that can
be cathartic to create that or to read
that like I said near the start there is
no right way to process this and there
is no right conclusion to come to but I
do think it is important that you
process this in one way or another
because the things we love are created
by people and people are fallible and
refusing to think about these things and
to think I will just separate the arts
from the art and don't think about it
the artists the art would not exist
without the artist the art does not
exist in a vacuum so to pretend like the
artist didn't create it and it was just
there that's that's not how anything
works so ignoring the issue I don't
think is good for anyone I think that's
just repression and kicking the can down
the road but I do think that with some
of these things it is possible to
process it to work through and to come
out the other end going I can still
enjoy this because it enriches my life
in my experiences by my connection with
this work with this art and this does
not have to connect me with the artists
whom I find issue with I don't know if
folks found this helpful
I didn't have as much of a grand overall
point this time this is partially
therapeutic for me for obvious reasons I
kind of needed to talk about the subject
without breaking down through rolling
again like I did last time I don't have
it in me this is a crazy month there's a
crazy year there's a crazy time if you
choose to do anything for pride I hope
you have fun if you choose to do nothing
for pride that is fine too we will get
through this in some way
we will fight and we will get through
thank you very much for watching
remember that you are beautiful you are
valid and you're loved you are the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned hopefully next time we can do
something more fun thank you so much for
watching if you are still listening you
can support me on patreon there's link
in the description and of course even if
you're not able to do that liking
subscribing commenting sharing all of
these things helped and I wish you the
best of times that you can have with
everything going on be safe be well be
kind
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]